Brazil’s President Dilma Rousseff is in
political free fall right now.
The lower house, which was dominated really
by her political supporters, voted in spite
of all that to bring charges against her for
cooking the books to hide election year spending.
The senate now has to concur. If it does,
which I think is better than a 50% chance,
the Senate will then hear those charges formally.
And you have to wonder—how did we get here?
It goes back actually before her reelection.
The state took such an important role in the
economy.
On the other hand, did not modernize the economy
to make it more competitive and help generate
sustainable economic growth.
So consequently, unemployment, an economy
that, really, these policies drove into the
ditch.
Undermining the state-run oil company so that
it lost money.
And then actually looting the coffers of that
oil company to sustain their own crooked,
crony campaigns.
That's how they got into this mess. And now,
it looks like impeachment is going to run
its course.
The world's attention is about to turn to
Brazil as Rio hosts the Summer Olympics.
Let us know how you think that this economic
and political crisis will affect Brazil's
image in the world.
Give us your comments. And also, give us ideas
on what other issues you'd like AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.